okay ladies and gentlemen
um I think we shall uh we're ready to
start here now and uh good evening and
uh welcome to the members councilors
I would say ladies and gentlemen but we
do have a couple in the public but um
uh I'll go through the five precautions
anyway if the fire alarm is activated
please locate the offices via the stairs
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
do not use the lifts assembling holy
Square on the green and officers will
assist you and advise when it's deemed
safe to return to the chamber
could everybody please ensure their
mobile phones are switched to silent and
not used to make or receive calls in the
chamber whilst the meetings in progress
uh I'm not sure if anyone's going to be
filming tonight
I'm assuming nobody is going to be
filming in which case I won't bother
going through those instructions
um does anybody any member wish to speak
under 20.1
nope in which case we will go on to
agenda item one which is apologies do we
have any apologies
[Music]
okay and I believe we have um Joe
Joanna cornfield as well
if there are any others
just Ken's counselor fellows and uh
that's it that's it okay in which case
we're going to agenda item two which is
uh Declarations of interest do we have
any Declarations of interest on the
agenda tonight
nope
agenda items three
is the minutes and that is the minutes
of the joint Transportation board
meeting held on the 13th of December
are we happy to accept those and in
which case can I have a proposer
councilor Carol Brown and the second are
councilor scoby
all agreed great thank you
and I have lost my
there we go uh so then we go on to
agenda item four which is parking and
waiting review
uh there are various ones here so I
think we've got about six in all if we
go through them and it's anybody got any
comments to make on any of these
no comments
nothing at all in which case on page
nine we have the options set out for us
um and
I would say then that we are going to uh
recommend it uh any other difference
amendments no right in which case where
support the officer's recommendation
about whether to consult on each of the
proposals
sorry
no nothing to say nobody's got anything
to say on these everyone's quite happy
with them okay in which case all happy
to support the officer's recommendation
in which case I need a proposer
Council Crow Brown in the second deck
councilor Quicken equipment all in favor
great thank you very much nobody's Gates
so that's fine then we go on to agenda
item five which is the highways forward
works
and I'm
happy to go through that
sorry uh yep item agenda item five I'm
struggling with my
with doing it on this but still
um
I'm happy to go through this uh a pen
each appendix because we don't have any
officer here of course so it is really a
matter of yelling out as we go through
appendix a is the road Footwear and
cycleway renewal and preservation scheme
are there any comments on this
that officers or members would like to
councilors would like to make
no
uh then we go on to agenda appendix B
drainage repairs and improvements
any comments there at all
nope
appendix C is Street lighting
most of which is
listed to be done
appendix D is transportation and safety
schemes the casualty reduction measures
anything there
no
uh externally funded schemes on the
active travel fund
which we have the a28 up update
has anybody got anything they want to
comment on these
yes I couldn't it did you want to have
thank you
um if we could get a little bit of
clavic ocean
um
this is on the appendix a developer
funded works
[Music]
th003124 this is to do with the
development at the top of top it'll be
Minister for the 214 houses going in
there part of the application involves
modification to the road layout entering
the roundabout on the 9229 at the top
um this is it comes under awaiting
submission
we've had a couple of meetings lately
with the developer can we clarify
exactly when this is likely to be
submitted to to Casey see because it
agreed at the beginning of this
development program that would be
construct the new construction would
take place before the development
actually started on the site and the
other thing that they are that we'd like
a bit of clarification on is the
entrance to the site which is going to
be on top little Street
um they're saying that is coming to TDC
shortly because at the moment the trucks
entering that site are coming right
through the village to the back of the
site on the on the west side and we've
had damage to walls and cars of God
knows what
um so can we clarify a little bit do we
know when
and who will make the submission for the
first of all for the modification of the
roundabout and for the entrance into the
site
thank you I'll have to ask accounts Crow
Brown if he knows any more than me
because we have no member here no
officer here to
um to help on that
nothing at all
[Music]
no
um I mean some of these awaiting
submission are
um planning applications that are
actually certainly one is out to appeal
so it's you know it covers
several things here so it's not actually
been determined that the application
will be approved yet so I've taken a
waiting submission to be that it's
pending and they've got a sort of
opinion just in case
um but maybe Council Crow Brown can can
update on that
thank you okay any other comments we
then go on to
um
yes
the two officers come down last Sunday
Last Summer to speak to uh
there's years of both Parish councils of
virgins in the Westgate
okay we will go on to appendix
let me see a little bit F now Bridge
works anything there at all nope
G is Traffic Systems
no comments no
in which case
we go on to the
H is um I believe that's Barry Lewis's
um
sponsored well it's not got funding yet
but uh the plan for the 20 mile per hour
speed limit in Sandston
and um let me go to I which is Street
works
and there are quite a few there that are
noted down
any comments at all
Right Moving swiftly on appendix J is
Sir public rights of way
um
do we have any comments questions
Council right
[Music]
residents to actually use them because
they don't use them and keep them
well used they're going to lose them
and maybe we should make that a little
bit more public that you know if you
want if you want to keep your public
rights away
use them
um it certainly helps particularly if
they you suddenly find they're subject
to a development exactly a planning
application because somebody's bought
the land yeah um so it certainly helps
if people do use them and that is
something that is being encouraged but
uh
any other comments
in which case we are through that and uh
if you have no more comments or
questions then this report is for
information and uh members happy to note
the report
yep yep thank you very much
agenda item six is active travel update
and uh now councilor Yates asked Mr
Phillip Mr Patrick to come tonight and
give us a quick talk
on active travel Mr piswick you are from
the part of the Senate cycling Forum yes
that's that's right Chef thank you and
uh so you have the floor yes thank you
chair for the opportunity to speak this
evening
um I'm representing the then it's
cycling Forum which was established in
the 1990s to encourage cycling and to
promote its benefits for the community
and for individuals we're also part of
an umbrella group known as active travel
Kent where we work collaboratively
collaboratively with similar groups
across the county
um we've enjoyed a good working
relationship with officers and members
in thanet over the last 20 years or so
and we're very grateful for that I'd
like if I may just to make a few
comments on on the report which
hopefully members have had a chance to
read that these are made in the order
that they appear in the report the first
section section one titled context we
finish a useful introduction for members
of of the board who might not be aware
of the changes to government policy over
the last two to three years but it's
already out of date on the 9th of March
the government announced a two-thirds
cut in funding for cycling and walking
to save money funding was cut from 300
million pounds a year to two to one 100
million pounds a year for the whole of
England for the next two years and to
put this into context if you've seen the
works that are taking place at the
m2a249 junction
um
to the continuing at the moment those
Works have cost 92 million and we've got
100 million for walking and cycling for
the whole of England for the next two
years in our opinion this is a false
economy um and it's a financial saving
that will lead to Greater expenditure
further down the line walking and
cycling have an enormous Health economic
and social benefits and in our opinion
it's unwise not to invest
so that's putting it into context
moving on to the birchington to Margate
scheme which has already been mentioned
this evening and is mentioned here in
paragraph 2.2
we as a group can see very little
benefit in in a route between
birchington and Westgate Railway
stations and we feel that improvements
to Sea Road between Burlington and
Westgate could be seen by members of the
public as a waste of money and they they
might risk public support for future
risk schemes where the benefits would be
much greater
if money is available for birchington to
Margate we would suggest that it might
be better spent on looking at
alternative routes for the sections of
the Viking Coastal Trail on the
Promenade where cycling is prohibited in
the summer months and wear sand and
seaweed make it difficult in the winter
months specifically these would be West
base and Mildred's Bay and Westbrook
um moving on then to um to the KCC
funding mentioned in paragraphs 3.5 and
again in 311 to 314.
um we're pleased that um that then
Industry Council has secured funding
from KCC for further development of the
local cycling and walking infrastructure
plan which we have seen a draft we
understand that the money is to be used
to employ consultants and we look
forward to being actively involved
um we broadly agree with the conclusions
and the priorities in that first draft
but we're concerned about the 12-month
time scale for the funding which doesn't
give very long for scheme planning
design consultation and everything that
should go with it
I'm also concerned that if the three
then itch schemes that are listed in
paragraph 313 failed when scored against
kcc's criteria then it's likely that
most all of the other schemes in the
draft will also fail in our opinion
there are very few quick wins and and
most of these are likely to be costly
and challenging to install
um so we we would like to see some sort
of member officer stakeholder event as
soon as practically as possible to have
a look at that document to agree a short
list in the priorities for further work
so that the money could be effectively
spent
and we'd also like to see some lower
costs but higher quality schemes such as
quiet streets and low traffic
neighborhoods given that funding for
large schemes is now extremely Limited
that's all I wanted to say this evening
and thank you once again chair and
members for the opportunity to speak
thank you Mr does anybody have any
questions
Council right
you met you mentioned some Mildred's Bay
um that one actually is quite an easy
one to work out as you come along the
front of the prom
you can actually come off of the prom
round the back and then come back on if
it's one of those boots it's a full
covering Beach when high tide comes up
which means people come families come
off of the beach and they come up they
come off onto the prom
and cycles and children running around
just don't mix
yes if I can come back on that yes I do
I agree entirely with with what you say
um there are parts of the route where
recycling is quite rightly prohibited in
in the summer months um I use it myself
most days of the week and and it's not
good
um what we're suggesting is that if
there is money
um for Burlington to Margate then we
look at places like some Mildred's Bay
like West Bay and Westbrook where
cycling is prohibited look at
alternative routes
um so that we've got a 12-month a cycle
that can be used for 12 months of the
year rather than just in in the winter
months so yeah I'd agree with what you
say I think there are alternatives that
could be looked at and if there's money
to spend then that would be a good place
to start
any other questions
thank you Mr Patrick
um you you you look to see if you could
get a a meeting
uh in the new Financial year to to to
discuss what other options there are uh
obviously there are elections coming up
so
um I think it's something that maybe the
current councilors can take forward and
pass on so that do office officers so
that that maybe is something that they
can come up with it'll be a TDC
uh arrangement of course
um I think KCC is uh
is probably involved but at a later
stage obviously it's TDC that comes up
with the schemes
um in fact there's one here that I
didn't even know about so and that is
the Saint Peter's one but in broadstairs
we're so used to not actually
um being considered for grants that um
it's par for the course that we didn't
get through this time either but I think
that's something that you should the
councilors should think about that they
do have a joint meeting
with organizations such as yourself
to get the best ideas forward
thank you very much and thank you very
much for coming you're more than welcome
to stay for the rest but I'm not sure if
you uh wish to do so
um okay in that case
um to
do members have any other questions or
comments on the report
this is for information only so we have
to
to note it
are we happy to note it yeah thank you
very much uh let me go on to agenda item
seven which is
the involvement in the highway aspects
of planning applications this is
essentially a a letter from David
Brazier who is the cabinet member for
highways and transport in KCC and I've
I'm assuming that everybody has looked
at it there are for me a few points here
that um
I would should we say have a discussion
over and others that I wouldn't but I
don't know what other what other
comments that members have on this
has anybody got any comments
Council scoby yeah I I felt it it felt a
bit heavy-handed and
um
the way we'd always worked with um KCC
before was very much in a
um
a spirit of cooperation and this feels
like we're being locked out and our
opinions
uh and not being sought in fact can't be
sought you know
thank you yes thank you 1.3 is is is
fairly
precise in that it is not possible to
have external discussions with
developers members of the public members
of the parish councils and other local
organizations and whilst I understand
the sentiment with planning
um yes it could have possibly been put
in a different way and I would suggest
that that's fine if it does include
developers as well
it's when it doesn't that there's a
problem
um it should if it's going to be one
that rule in it should be for everyone
the other thing I noticed was um the
there is a heavy uh
Reliance on 1.9 which is the presumption
in favor of development which I accept
is the current plan but there have been
talks that that may be changed in the
future
um there are quite a few things with
consultations on planning rules
1.14
is the transport assessment which
KCC say they are the people who will um
that they will be the people who decide
whether it's a good assessment or not
covering the right area
um now I've seen traffic assessments for
planning applications particularly large
ones
where the comparison that they have done
with other areas have not been
not really been acceptable they and so I
think that's another point that we have
to look at very carefully
if they are if they are saying that
they're going to assess with these uh
travel comparisons are transport
comparisons are valid then I think we
have to look at them very carefully
because I know from personal experience
of two at least two that were not valid
at all
they were related compared with our
areas that were completely different
so
um yes it's an interesting
an interesting letter
um and also 1.17 that they are not
looking to accommodate cars
which in Senate will be very interesting
bearing in mind the traffic situation we
have at the moment
um we are asked only to note this report
so I think if everyone's agreed that
it's noted councilor Crow Brown yeah I
just wanted to say chair we residents
and Minister a month and feel we really
are fighting against the tide we've just
had a another planning application South
amongst and robe between the two
Villages 95 dwellings uh potentially
that could be 400 in the end on lanes
that just cannot cope
yes but it's difficult
I think we've already found out that the
traffic situation now is getting
impossible
um and hopefully that will be brought
forward after the elections
but are we happy to note the comments
thank you very much well that concludes
the business for this evening it's a
short and sharp meeting tonight and I
thank you for your attendance and I also
say thank you very much members for um
the past year it hands over to
chairmanship hands over to TDC after
this meeting so
I wish everyone
Good Fortune if they are standing for
election thank you for your Sterling
work
very much